-Une championne olympique,
une athlète engagée,
une mère de famille,
une ingénieure
et une figure inspirante.
Est-ce que ça vous va
si je vous présente
comme ça,
Estelle Mossely ?
-C'est une belle présentation,
merci.
-J'ai rien oublié ?
-Non, tout est bien.
Merci pour cette présentation.
Oui, oui, ça me va.
C'est un peu
toutes les facettes
de ce que je suis.
-Regardez cette photo.
Nous sommes
au mois d'août,
c'est votre anniversaire,
le 19 août exactement,
2016, à Rio.
Et c'est évidemment le jour
où vous êtes sacrée championne
olympique
dans cette discipline
qui, jusqu'ici,
ne sacrait pas les femmes,
la boxe.
Qu'est-ce qui a changé,
Estelle, à partir
de ce jour-là
dans votre vie ?
-Beaucoup de choses.
Beaucoup de choses ont changé.
Bah, ça a été
la consécration
après énormément
d'années de travail,
après beaucoup
de sacrifices, après...
C'est un rêve.
-Mmh mmh.
-Qui prend jour et puis...
C'est surtout le travail, l'équipe
qui est là autour, la famille,
on n'a pas fait ça
pour rien.
-Là, vous avez explosé
de la France entière,
donc ça aussi,
ça a changé.
-Oui. En plus.
Ca a énormément changé,
je suis passée de l'anonymat
à tout le monde me connaît,
je ne faisais plus
les courses, je n'allais quasiment
plus dehors et c'était bien,
c'était des bons moments
à vivre,
parce que c'était
des retours de partout,
mais des retours
hyper positifs.
C'est ce que je trouve particulier
autour des Jeux olympiques,
les retours des gens,
ça faisait du bien en fait.
J'avais l'impression d'avoir
transmis des messages
à travers cette médaille.
-Lesquels ?
-Comme quoi les choses
sont possibles,
des messages pour les femmes
aussi, parce que
je pratique un sport
assez masculin,
la boxe.
-On va en parler.
-Et donc, voilà,
qu'on peut se démarquer
dans un milieu d'hommes
quelque part.
En plus, la finale que j'ai eue,
c'est une finale hyper serrée,
donc ma ténacité
à faire les choses.
C'est tout ça
comme messages,
que des messages positifs.
Ca m'a fait du bien
et je pense que la médaille a fait
du bien à beaucoup de monde.
-Alors, on va rembobiner
un petit peu,
quand on est une petite fille,
à Créteil,
qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'à un moment donné,
on dit, je veux
faire de la boxe ?
-J'étais pas à Créteil,
je suis née à Créteil,
mais j'ai commencé
à Champigny-sur-Marne la boxe.
J'ai toujours habité
entre Champigny et Chennevières
et je pousse la salle
de boxe de Champigny,
parce que j'avais testé
plein de sports
et au départ,
c'est les sports,
parce que nos parents
nous inscrivent à un sport.
-Une activité.
-Exactement.
Jusqu'à ce qu'on nous demande
notre avis
et là, c'était la boxe.
Mon père était content.
Maman, moins.
J'ai fait 3 ans
de danse classique quand même.
J'ai fait du patinage artistique.
-Elle a eu peur ?
-Elle a eu peur et puis
c'était pas ce qu'elle voulait
forcément pour sa petite fille.
Elle m'habillait en princesse.
J'allais à l'école
avec des robes blanches.
C'était l'opposé total.
Et puis, je commence la boxe
et finalement,
ça me plaît énormément.
-Qu'est-ce qui vous a plu ?
-J'ai trouvé
ce que j'attendais d'un sport.
C'était physique,
c'était dur, c'était...
Il fallait quand même
réfléchir beaucoup.
Le combat, c'est
beaucoup de réflexion.
-C'est de la tactique, un combat.
-Exactement. Et en fait,
tout ça s'entremêlait et il fallait
être bon partout pour réussir.
Et ça m'a plu.
En plus, dans un sport
où, quand j'ai commencé,
j'étais la seule fille
dans cette salle, j'ai été
accueillie comme il fallait.
-Il y avait quoi comme regard
sur vous ?
-De la part des entraîneurs,
à la fois,
on faisait attention à moi,
parce que j'étais une fille,
on mettait pas ça de côté,
j'étais la seule fille
dans une salle de boxe,
j'ai commencé à 12 ans, les gars
avec qui je mettais les gants,
ils avaient 15 ans, 15, 16 ans,
donc on les avertissait,
tu vas mettre les gants avec elle,
fais attention.
Et pourtant, dans tout
ce qui est technique du sport,
intensité,
tous les à-côtés du combat,
qui sont la majorité
de ce qu'on fait à l'entraînement,
là, c'était comme tout le monde.
-Regardez cette photo.
La boxe, quand même,
c'est un sport difficile, au sens
propre du terme, c'est dur.
On donne et on prend
des coups, Estelle.
Vous l'avez dit,
après votre médaille d'or,
ça a ouvert des perspectives
à des jeunes filles
et on a vu un afflux massif
dans les salles de boxe
de petites filles
voulant faire
de la boxe, car c'était possible,
parce qu'on pouvait devenir
Estelle Mossely ou Sarah Ourahmoune,
elle aussi médaillée
à Rio. Ce physique-là,
donner des coups
et en recevoir quand on est
une jeune fille,
comment on l'appréhende ?
-Ca ne me posait
pas problème.
Déjà, quand on rentre
dans un sport comme celui-ci,
il faut accepter
de prendre des coups.
On va prendre des coups. Ca ne
me posait absolument pas problème.
-Comment on accepte de prendre
des coups, de se faire mal
et de recevoir des coups
qui peuvent faire mal ?
-Franchement,
c'est aussi notre part
d'histoire quelque part,
c'est la vie qu'on mène
qui fait qu'on est prêt
à être autant dans le dur.
Cette médaille d'or... Je voulais
devenir championne olympique
pour plein de raisons,
je voulais être la meilleure
dans mon sport.
Et pour prendre une revanche
sur la vie par rapport
à l'histoire de mes parents
qui sont venus en France.
-Vous êtes une enfant d'immigrés,
ça compte.
-Ca compte énormément.
C'est des parents
qui ont fait
de très grandes études...
-Et qui ont été déclassés
en arrivant.
-Exactement. Donc tout ça,
dans la vie que je mène
jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
c'est une revanche que j'avais envie
de prendre pour eux,
ça a forgé mon caractère
et il se trouve
que je me suis retrouvée
dans ce sport, dans la boxe
et devenir championne olympique,
c'était le Graal,
c'était pas juste devenir
la meilleure dans mon sport,
c'était impacter au-delà.
-Un accomplissement.
-Oui, mais surtout impacter au-delà.
C'est exactement ce que j'ai vécu,
ça n'a pas été juste
être championne olympique,
ça a été
tous les messages à côté
qui ont découlé
de cette médaille.
La médaille d'or,
la médaille des Jeux,
ça a un très gros impact social.
-C'est en cela que les Jeux
sont au-dessus de tout ?
-Ouais, je pense.
C'est en cela que ça dépasse
une autre médaille.
J'ai été championne du monde
quelques mois avant, et pourtant,
c'est pas pareil.
-Non. Outre la médiatisation,
il y a cet impact
dont vous parlez.
-Il y a cet impact social.
On rencontre du monde.
J'ai obtenu une Légion d'honneur
juste après cette médaille.
On croise
énormément de monde
de différents milieux,
des politiques,
des artistes,
et on devient un sportif important,
mais on devient
aussi une personne importante.
C'est là qu'on peut mener
d'autres projets.
-Ces autres projets,
on va en parler,
mais je voudrais qu'on reste
un peu encore sur le ring,
est-ce qu'on a peur,
Estelle, parfois ?
-J'ai pas peur.
Quand je monte sur le ring,
je n'ai pas peur,
je fais toujours en sorte
de m'entraîner
du mieux que je peux
pour justement ne pas avoir
cette peur en montant sur le ring.
Je peux peut-être avoir peur
à l'entraînement,
avant une piste, quand je sais
que je vais finir
limite en vomissant
après une séance d'entraînement,
j'appréhende pendant 3 jours.
-Expliquez ce qu'est une piste,
pour les téléspectateurs.
-On a un sport très cardio,
on fait du fractionné
sur des pistes d'athlétisme.
On court énormément.
Et on pousse
notre corps à l'extrême,
notre coeur à l'extrême,
c'est pas ce que je préfère
dans les entraînements,
mais c'est le passage
obligatoire
et parfois, je termine
mes séances d'entraînement
après 10 100 mètres,
5 400 mètres,
limite en vomissant et à 4 pattes.
Mais là, ouais,
j'ai peur avant.
2, 3 jours avant,
j'angoisse.
-C'est la réaction
de votre corps qui...
-J'ai mal au ventre
3h avant de monter
sur la piste, alors que,
quand j'arrive sur le ring,
ça ne m'arrive absolument pas.
Je pense
que ça ne m'arrive pas,
parce que je fais en sorte
à chaque fois
d'avoir cette peur avant,
de l'avoir
dans les entraînements.
-Vous la gérez comme ça.
-Je la gère, je la dépasse
et quand j'arrive sur le ring,
je n'ai pas à avoir peur,
puisque j'ai fait le travail.
-Comment préparez-vous un combat ?
Est-ce que c'est
vous-même et vous seule
ou c'est aussi
l'étude de votre adversaire ?
Comment ça se passe ?
Vous avez dit que c'était aussi
tactique, avant et pendant.
-C'est un tout.
On étudie l'adversaire
ou les potentiels adversaires.
Sur un combat professionnel,
on a un adversaire, c'est planifié
longtemps à l'avance.
Sur un format olympique,
c'est un tournoi,
donc on va rencontrer
différents adversaires
et il y a un tirage
au sort au départ.
Donc on étudie
les adversaires
et puis on fait en sorte
de rayer au maximum
tous les défauts qu'on peut avoir
au fur et à mesure.
Et ça, ça se fait
avec les entraîneurs.
C'est un travail d'équipe. On est
dans un sport individuel,
mais ça reste
un gros travail d'équipe.
Pour moi, c'est
un travail familial limite.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Quand j'arrive au combat,
mon équipe,
c'est ma famille,
on est tout le temps
ensemble.
Je me suis entourée
de personnes très proches.
Il y a aussi mes enfants, mes
parents. C'est un travail familial.
-On va y venir à vos enfants, c'est
quelque chose de très important
et dans la vie qui a changé
depuis cette médaille,
il y a aussi évidemment
ces 2 garçons
qui sont arrivés, mais
quand des jeunes filles vous disent,
j'aimerais faire de la boxe,
comment vous arrivez
à les convaincre
qu'elles peuvent y aller,
qu'elles doivent y aller ?
Qu'est-ce que ça va leur apporter ?
-Déjà,
elles me voient. Et moi,
quand je vais à la rencontre,
ça m'arrive beaucoup d'aller
à la rencontre des personnes,
des gens,
des jeunes beaucoup,
et des fois, j'arrive même
avec mes enfants,
alors, quand on voit
que j'ai réussi
dans le contexte
dans lequel je suis,
ça laisse
pousser au champ des possibles.
Et moi, je dis toujours,
la seule chose qu'il faut pas avoir
peur, c'est peur des coups.
C'est un sport
où on prend des coups.
Il faut pas aimer ça...
-Qu'est-ce que
ça apporte ? Vous leur dites,
si tu fais de la boxe,
tu seras plus...
Plus, quoi ?
-Il faut toujours oser. Il y en a
qui sont dans la crainte,
qui vont me dire, je sais pas
si je suis à ma place.
C'est pas une question de place.
C'est soi et soi.
C'est à nous de décider
où on a envie d'aller. Alors, oui,
il faut pas
avoir peur des coups,
mais si on veut tester un sport,
il faut oser. Je dis beaucoup ça.
Il faut oser pousser
la porte d'une salle de boxe.
C'est un sport
comme un autre.
-Mais difficile, exigeant
d'un point de vue
physique. Vous avez parlé de vos
vomissements en fin de piste, etc.
C'est un sport qui exige
du corps et du mental.
-Oui, c'est
un sport exigeant,
mais il y a aussi des paliers.
Quand on commence, on sera pas
tout de suite dans le dur.
On sera dans la technique,
dans la tactique,
et c'est un sport qui est
très complet et on peut
le pratiquer différemment.
-Et le plaisir
dans tout ça ?
A quel moment il vient ?
Quand on gagne un combat ?
-Non, le plaisir vient
à l'entraînement, quand on a
réussi un enchaînement,
que ça devient
limite instantané.
Il vient quand on est
en face d'un adversaire,
parce qu'il y a le combat,
mais il y a les sparrings,
où c'est des essais
de combats, on va dire.
Où on n'a pas réussi
pendant X semaines à boxer
contre cet adversaire et finalement,
on arrive à esquiver la majorité
des coups. Là, il y a du plaisir.
On a franchi une étape de plus.
Le plaisir, il vient même
sur une séance physique,
en musculation,
ou sur une piste justement
où on a dépassé un chrono.
Tout ça, c'est du plaisir.
-Alors, vous avez
parlé de sacrifice
tout à l'heure
quand vous avez revu
cette médaille d'or olympique,
c'était l'aboutissement aussi
de tous les sacrifices.
Vous avez fait
des grandes études aussi.
L'école, c'était aussi
très important pour vos parents,
vous l'avez expliqué.
Comment avez-vous tenu le coup,
Estelle ? Cette détermination,
vous êtes allée
la chercher
à l'intérieur de vous-même ?
-Oui.
Oui, et puis je n'ai
pas connu autre chose.
Je... j'étais jeune,
j'avais 12 ans,
j'ai fait du sport, très vite, ça a
été 2 fois par semaine, puis 3 fois,
il y avait les études à côté,
ça a toujours fait partie de ma vie.
C'est plus quand j'en suis sorti,
je me suis dit, comment j'ai fait ?
-J'ai pas assez profité
de ma jeunesse, aussi, peut-être ?
-Il y a des choses
qu'on ne fait pas,
on s'en rend pas
forcément compte.
J'étais étudiante, avec des
horaires quand même conséquents,
une école où les horaires
n'étaient pas adaptés à mon rythme
de sportive de haut niveau.
Je ratais l'école, il fallait
rattraper. Donc il y a des choses
que je ne faisais pas. C'est ça,
ma part de sacrifice.
Il y a plein de moments
que mes copines vivaient
que, moi, je ne vivais pas.
Mais je vivais quand même des choses
tellement hors du commun à côté.
-Vous avez eu conscience
de ça très vite.
-Oui, j'ai voyagé, je suis
rentrée en équipe de France,
je voyageais à l'international.
C'est des choses
que les personnes de mon âge
ne faisaient pas forcément,
rares sont ceux qui le faisaient.
J'ai eu une accélération...
Ca a été un accélérateur
de maturité aussi beaucoup.
J'ai côtoyé des gens
de différents milieux,
de différentes nationalités,
ça amène à voir
les choses différemment
vis-à-vis de la société,
vis-à-vis de plein de choses.
Vraiment, ça a été un accélérateur
au niveau de ma maturité.
Enormément.
-On l'a dit, vous avez fait
des brillantes études, vous êtes
ingénieure.
Comment est-ce que vous arrivez
à concilier aujourd'hui
encore cette double vie
entre guillemets ?
-Aujourd'hui, et après la médaille
d'or, c'est ce qui a aussi changé,
cette médaille d'or aux Jeux, j'ai
pris le temps, j'ai eu un enfant,
et je suis passée
professionnelle dans mon sport
et j'ai eu la possibilité
de ne faire que ça.
Donc mon métier d'ingénieur,
je l'ai pas finalement poursuivi,
puisque je suis passée
professionnelle
et je n'ai fait que mon sport
jusqu'à présent.
-On peut vivre alors de son sport ?
-Oui, chose que je ne pensais pas.
Je ne voyais pas passer
professionnelle, on ne vivait pas
de la boxe, encore moins une femme.
Et la médaille d'or a tout changé.
J'ai eu des contrats,
qui m'ont permis
de ne faire que ça,
et là, j'ai dit, ça vaut le coup,
parce que c'est...
J'ai la possibilité d'être
à la hauteur de la concurrence.
-Mmh.
-Et pour moi, concilier sa vie
entre un sport très exigeant,
un sport de haut niveau,
et devoir travailler
à côté, j'aurais pas été
dans la capacité
d'être à la hauteur
de la concurrence.
Ca aurait posé
un problème à un moment.
Ca aurait été compliqué.
J'aime aller au bout des choses.
Et dans certaines conditions,
on ne peut pas aller au bout.
-Oui. Le tout,
vous l'avez dit,
en assumant le fait
d'avoir une vie de femme,
en ayant des enfants,
tout en continuant d'être
une sportive de haut niveau.
A aucun moment, Estelle,
vous vous êtes dit,
ce choix-là, ce sera
l'un ou l'autre, c'est-à-dire
la boxe de haut niveau
ou les enfants ?
-Jamais.
Jamais. Euh, jamais.
Le sport, je le vis...
-C'est nouveau,
ça, hein ? Vous êtes
la nouvelle génération,
parce que les autres athlètes,
quels que soient les sports,
se sont interdits
de faire des enfants.
-Oui, beaucoup. C'est ce que j'ai
remarqué après ma médaille d'or
et par rapport aux retours
que j'avais eus. Finalement,
quand on fait le bilan, beaucoup
de femmes se sont interdit
et c'est un message...
-Et pour qui, un jour,
c'était trop tard.
-Oui. En plus.
Je fais les choses pour ne pas vivre
avec des regrets.
J'aime bien faire les choses
comme je l'entends
et pas comme on souhaite
me l'imposer.
Et pour moi,
voilà, les enfants,
c'était une suite logique
dans mon parcours de femme,
après une médaille d'or aux Jeux.
J'avais besoin déjà de repos,
après des années hyper chargées,
où j'ai eu ma part
de sacrifices.
J'avais besoin de faire ça
et d'avoir un enfant
et je l'ai fait
et puis j'en ai fait un 2e,
parce que, voilà,
il se trouve
que ça faisait aussi partie
de ma vie de femme.
J'étais en couple, j'avais envie
d'un autre enfant.
Et à aucun moment,
je me suis dit,
ça m'arrêtera dans ma carrière.
A aucun moment.
-A ce moment-là,
votre outil de travail,
c'est votre corps.
-C'est mon corps.
Bien sûr, c'est mon corps,
mais...
Je me dis, quand même, aujourd'hui,
on a assez de moyens
pour faire des choses.
-Mmh.
-Ce qui nous freine,
c'est plus ce qu'on entend.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on entend ?
-Beaucoup de choses,
on entend,
des athlètes ont peur
de le faire,
de peur d'être mises à l'écart
dans les équipes,
dans les équipes de France,
elles ont peur, peut-être
un manque de confiance en soi aussi,
on se dit, est-ce que je serai
à la hauteur de la concurrence
avec un enfant ?
J'ai pas peur de tout ça.
-La parenthèse est grande,
on peut pas boxer en étant enceinte.
Vous avez boxé
jusqu'à quel terme ?
-La 1re grossesse,
j'ai totalement arrêté.
La reprise a été difficile.
J'ai arrêté plus d'un an.
La 2e, par contre,
j'ai continué à m'entraîner
jusqu'à 7 mois
et j'ai repris 6 semaines
après mon accouchement.
-C'est phénoménal.
Vous mesurez ce que c'est
pour des femmes normales,
comme moi, par exemple ?
C'est phénoménal, ça.
-Je sais que c'est... Voilà,
tout le monde ne peut pas le faire,
mais je m'entraînais
telle une athlète de haut niveau,
35h par semaine,
donc...
Il faut avoir conscience de ce
qu'on est capable de faire aussi.
Souvent, ces femmes qui décident...
Il y en a qui décident de faire
leur enfant après leur carrière,
c'est un choix, c'est très bien,
mais parfois, c'est imposé.
Et pourtant, on a la possibilité
de, on peut le faire.
-Mais ça veut dire
que vous avez trouvé aussi
un entourage qui vous a accompagnée
et qui a cru en ça
et qui vous a dit,
c'est possible.
-Oui, complètement.
On peut le faire.
C'est bien d'être entouré,
c'est mieux, il le faut.
Pour ma 1re grossesse,
j'étais...
-C'est des coachs, des médecins,
des psys, des... tout ?
-Pour ma 1re grossesse,
où je me suis totalement arrêtée,
je savais que je ne serais pas
forcément aidée. Par ma fédération,
voilà,
c'était moi et moi, il fallait
que je constitue mon équipe
et ces personnes qui m'entouraient.
Donc ça a été mon kiné,
mes entraîneurs
et beaucoup ma famille.
Je me retrouve
quand même avec un enfant et je dois
m'entraîner et mon enfant
n'était pas en crèche
pendant un an, donc ma famille
m'aidait beaucoup.
Et pour ma 2e grossesse,
j'avais déjà cet entourage,
ces bases solides, c'est pour ça
aussi que j'ai pu continuer
la préparation aussi longtemps
et revenir aussi vite.
Les choses étaient déjà en place.
Et très rapidement, les gens ont
pris le pas et puis ont vu...
Ils ont confiance aussi
en mon travail, en ma capacité
de travailler. Les choses sont
possibles. Je le dis.
Oui, elles sont possibles,
mais il faut...
-Il faut qu'il y en ait une
qui fasse le pas la 1re fois.
Quand vous avez entendu
Clarisse Agbégnénou raconter
qu'en arrivant avec Athéna
dans sa fédé de judo,
ils l'ont regardée,
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
qu'on en fasse
de ce couffin ?
Et ça a été difficile
de leur faire accepter que, oui,
elle peut m'accompagner,
je peux l'allaiter, etc.
Aujourd'hui, vous êtes
plusieurs, il y en a
dans des sports co.
Avez-vous l'impression
d'avoir participé à une forme
de transformation et de progrès ?
-Complètement. Je participe encore.
Je vise
des objectifs sportifs
très importants et j'ai mes 2
enfants. Et ils sont en bas âge.
A côté, le matin,
il faut que je me lève
pour les emmener à l'école et que je
rentre à temps après l'entraînement.
-Est-ce que ça participe
pas aussi
d'une forme d'équilibre
et une manière
de cloisonner les choses, d'être
dans son sport et sa performance,
puis dans la vie
avec tout ce que ça a
de positif et de difficile ?
-Oui, c'est pour ça que je l'ai
refait une 2e fois.
Au début, c'était
mes études et le sport.
C'était dur, mais psychologiquement,
c'est limite plus facile.
Et ensuite, ça a été mes enfants
et le sport. Et...
Je pense que si je m'étais freinée
sur une partie
de ce que je voulais faire,
ça aurait posé problème à la longue,
psychologiquement.
-Pour vous ?
-Ouais.
Que là, bon,
c'est dur parfois,
c'est physique,
c'est une organisation,
mais je suis épanouie
dans tout ce que je fais.
Ca joue énormément.
-Vous les emmenez
souvent, vos garçons. Quel regard
ils portent sur leur maman ?
D'ailleurs, vous avez écrit
un livre sur le sport
et sur la place que ça a
dans votre vie pour vos enfants.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
de maman ? Qui va boxer.
-Ils veulent connaître
mon emploi du temps,
ce que je vais faire,
les compétitions.
J'ai eu un accident récemment,
alors le plus grand, maman,
tu vas pouvoir reboxer ?
Tu vas faire les Jeux ?
Ils sont venus
aux qualifications.
Ca m'a permis
de leur faire comprendre,
parce qu'ils sont petits.
A 6 ans, on commence à comprendre,
à 3 ans, un peu moins,
ce que c'est
les Jeux olympiques.
Il faut passer
par toute une explication.
Mais ils sont contents
et je pense
que... j'essaie de les faire
participer au maximum
pour qu'ils s'imprègnent
de tout, parce que c'est
une richesse et on a les Jeux
olympiques chez nous.
Et j'essaie de les ramener
au maximum, dès que je peux,
pour qu'ils comprennent.
Pour moi, le sport a été
un accélérateur de vie
et ça peut l'être
pour eux.
-Vous pensez
que, de toute façon,
ils feront du sport,
vos enfants ?
Parce que c'est essentiel
à leur équilibre
d'ores et déjà ou pas ?
-Oui.
Ils font déjà du sport.
Ils en font pas à haut niveau,
mais ils font du sport.
Bah, c'est l'éducation que j'ai
reçue. Le sport, c'est comme
aller à l'école,
ça fait partie de l'éducation.
Demain, je ne sais pas
s'ils seront champions,
c'est la seule différence.
-Que voulez-vous
que le sport leur apporte ?
-Juste un équilibre.
Un équilibre de vie.
Je veux aussi...
Pour moi,
c'est la santé, le sport.
Donc il y a ça aussi à prendre
en compte. C'est la discipline.
L'école aussi, c'est la discipline,
mais je pense que les deux,
quand on peut faire la bascule
entre l'un et l'autre,
ça permet d'être plus discipliné,
de comprendre plus les choses
et d'accepter plus,
l'exigence.
On me demandait beaucoup
de choses à l'entraînement
et on me demandait beaucoup
de choses à l'école aussi.
Et de passer de l'un à l'autre
avec des victoires, des défaites
et de se dire,
on est exigeant avec moi
et ça exige de la discipline,
mais c'est pas pour rien,
c'est pour me mener
à ça, ici,
c'est pour mener à ça,
ici. Voilà. Ca permet
de comprendre
que la discipline est importante
et que, parfois, on est exigeant
envers nous, mais pas pour rien.
-Que serait
devenue la petite Estelle Mossely
sans le sport ?
-Je pense
qu'une Estelle Mossely sans sport,
ça aurait été compliqué.
Ce n'est pas possible,
très honnêtement.
Le sport, ça a toujours été
mon équilibre.
Depuis petite, je pratique du sport
et je me vois
très, très mal sans sport.
Je sais... Ca m'a permis aussi
de me canaliser,
je suis quelqu'un
qui est très active
depuis toujours. Ca me permet
de canaliser mes émotions aussi.
Donc... C'est mon équilibre.
-Non, c'était pas possible.
-C'est pas possible.
-Une dernière question,
vous avez beaucoup parlé
de ces valeurs du sport,
du fait que la France
organise des Jeux olympiques.
Ce pays et son rapport au sport,
un peu compliqué,
notamment quand on est une femme,
quand on est jeune
et qu'on doit concilier les études
et le sport de haut niveau,
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait changer,
Estelle ?
-Il y a beaucoup de choses
à changer, je trouve.
Euh... Et surtout les bases.
Parce que, finalement,
on a beaucoup de talents
en France et on a
de très grands champions aussi,
mais parfois, on a l'impression
que c'est un peu le hasard,
alors qu'on a énormément
de ressources ici. On peut être
parmi le top...
top 3, on peut l'être,
mais au niveau de la base,
il y a des choses à changer.
Je me suis entraînée
aux Etats-Unis pendant 2 ans,
et quand on voit que le sport permet
aussi d'aller à l'école...
-Permet d'obtenir
une porte
dans des grandes universités.
-Voilà.
Quand j'étais en école d'ingénieur,
un professeur m'a dit, pourquoi
tu fais du sport de haut niveau ?
Je comprends pas.
Ca va t'amener où ?
T'es à l'école, en école
d'ingénieur. C'est l'effet inverse.
-Il faut choisir ici.
-Oui.
Et limite, on comprend pas.
Et non, je veux pas choisir.
Et je pense que personne
n'a besoin de choisir.
Mais, pour ça, il faut
changer la base,
la mentalité à sa base
et ne pas penser
que c'est soit le sport
soit les études.
Ca peut être
très complémentaire
et au contraire, ça peut permettre
justement d'arriver
à se dépasser.
Réussir à concilier les deux,
ça peut permettre de se dépasser.
-Combien de temps
encore sur un ring ?
-Pas 10 ans, hein. Je suis
plus à la fin qu'au début.
-C'est pour ça
que je vous demande.
Encore combien de temps ?
-Pas plus de 2 ans.
-Oui ?
-Oui. Ce sera mes derniers Jeux,
c'est certain.
-Oui.
-Je... Derrière,
j'ai l'envie quand même de faire
quelques combats professionnels
qui me mèneront
au maximum de ce que je peux faire,
donc la réunification des titres.
C'est ce que je vise. Après,
je tournerai la page.
Mais je resterai
quand même dans le sport.
-Merci d'avoir écrit
les belles pages du sport français.
-Merci. Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA